da bist du ja dass ich auch mal im kanal
sind gemeldet das waren machen wir heute
experiment papier trockene haut die sie
hinter mir videos unfassbar häufig
kommentare die sowas
also von wegen hätte ich mir so viele
abschaffen doch heutiges video habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich einfach auch mal so
ein experiment starten könnten zwar
recht schwindelig ich werde mir heute
mit meinem laptop einen neuen
youtube-kanal erstellt und wir schauen
ob dieser kanal innerhalb von einer
woche
100.000 abonnenten erreichen wird ob wir
das zusammen schaffen können wir starten
unseren computer ich bin nicht so häufig
am laptop hatte ich dann okay ich glaube
wenn man finger benutzen wir gehen nun
erstmal auf die webseite youtube das die
kamera profi alter wir befinden uns hier
auf der website youtube das heißt wir
gehen jetzt erst mal auf anmelden hier
oben und werden uns ein neues konto
erstellen braucht ihr wirklich vor und
nachname luca luka dass mein name die
mährische verdienen luca luka gmail.com
es bereits vergeben
wir erwarten aber verdammt ernst lupu 12
3 ist natürlich auch schon vergeben 1234
ist okay luc roux 1234 morgen auf einem
geschlecht gibt es weiblich männlich ich
möchte dies nicht beantwortung
benutzerdefiniert luca ich möchte
gezeichnet werden als sonstiges
datenschutz und bedingungen das ist ganz
wichtig dass uns das jetzt alles okay
lukaku
ich stelle mir den ganzen rest hier eine
dann wie man wieder wenn diese
langweilige kaffee vorbei
es dauert so beschissen youtube kanal zu
erstellen auf jeden fall hab ich den
kanal erstellt er heißt luca der kanal
banner sagt genau das aus was ich möchte
da du keine neuesten videos hast wird
dies nicht auf deinen kanal angezeigt um
inhalte hinzuzufügen lade ein video hoch
ist unscharf ok dann hatte ich da jetzt
mal mio videos online weiter werde ich
das nicht zeigen damit jetzt auf den
kanal dann in denen es mir selbst leiten
also sieht der kanadier frage aus aber
ich hab jetzt hier im video ich habe
einen aufruf der kanal ist also mehr
oder weniger fertig erstellten meine
lieben freunde das heißt hier du da vor
der linse hat das vertrauen
hey ich brauche jetzt eure hilfe meine
liebe freunde und zwar möchte ich das
hier jetzt alle nach unten in diesem
video beschreibung geschaut von diesem
video egal ob ihr habt mir in die seite
oder auf dem computer oder auf der
playstation
auch immer sich youtube videos auf der
playstation anschaut je in die video
beschreibung von diesem video und klickt
auf den link denn somit abonniert hier
diesen kanal und ich versuche 100.000
abonnenten in sieben tagen zu erreichen
damit bei der damen und herren wir den
und youtube
bla bla bla bla bla silva creating
kriegt man 100.000 abonnenten
das ist so ein preis und den möchte ich
innerhalb von einer woche bekommen hat
ihm eine community die luke ruder
schaffen sollte werde ich diese silver
award verlosen einer von euch hat dann
die chance so einen preis zu bekommen
eines der preis jetzt so aussieht und
vor ein paar jahren sagen die noch so
richtig beschissen aus also klickt auf
den link in der beschreibung abonniert
den kanal
der silberblick abonniert diesen luxus
kanal und falls sie der kanal nach
sieben tagen 100000 enten haben wird
werde ich den ort der nicht von youtube
bekomme an euch verschenken still um ihn
das war sie vom heutigen video
dankeschön an alle von euch von danke
dass sie das video angeschaut hat wird
das video gefallen hat das gerne mal
einen daumen hoch da ich habe heute mal
ein bisschen anders geschnitten weil ich
gerade switches von adobe premiere auch
final cut also auf apple schnittprogramm
ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen ist und
jetzt klickt auf den link in der video
beschreibungen lassen aber im nu kanal
da jeder für das erste bluetooth
[Musik]